nous allons terminer cette émission bien
entendu par l'éclat meuse 10 question
que je vous pose à tous les deux
évidemment aujourd'hui alors fanny
ardant votre mot préféré tant pis
marcello lumière lumière le mot que vous
détestez ortin fisc votre drogue
favorite à l'eau chaude des salles de
bains dois le dire et cigarettes le son
le bruit que vous aimez l brute des
ciseaux dans les cheveux le treuil le
son le bruit que vous détestez les gens
qui mangent il est en écoute on savait
qu'ils tirent du coton aic qui mangent
du coton et samedi j'étais jeune je
voulais juste vous souffrirez les motos
les motos votre juron blasphème ou gros
mots favoris magath son contrat ça veut
dire quoi
je sais pas de traduire en sait jamais
ce que je commence à me dire tu es sûr
pour vous pas bon et vous dieu géomètre
dieux géants m oui c'est un jardin
suspendu dans la région de la province
qu'est ce que les géomètres ils ont
détruit l'italie alors le grand da silva
dieu seul appelé géomètre deuxième est
un mou femmes pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque l'a fait qu'à rabat la
fée carabosse
moi je voudrais mettre mon père je peux
être sentimental dans sa vie dans sa
villa et n'a pas vu passer beaucoup de
billets
on appuie et soutient à l'ajout de loi
devra ainsi passer très je vise opt
l'autre côté marc mais le métier fait
venir dont vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
bourreau comptable parce que je le fais
je suis ce que ça veut dire
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné un la
chèvre de monsieur seguin le sapin et
enfin si dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous
après votre mort l'entendre vous dire
qu'à billère salut l'artiste
restez vous descendez où l ascenseur
[Musique]